[Musica]
sono un prestigiatore non un mago che sa
di esoterico
non mi sento però nemmeno di essere un
presti digitatore che è una parola
orribile inventata di sana pianta da un
mio collega francese nell'ottocento ed è
anche sbagliata perché racconta
solamente della destrezza delle mani
vedremo che è molto più complesso e così
è dunque vorrei invitarvi a curiosare
oltre una porta solitamente chiusa in
questa mia isola che non c'è
ma dove tutto si può immaginare e per
farlo non o dalle grandi mercy scena
volutamente o solamente 1 2 3 4 5 e 6
carte tutto qui però per cominciare tre
di queste carte chiaramente da parte una
due tre lontane sul tavolo di modo che
in mano ovviamente ne rimangono 123456 e
la gente dice un momento momento se
tutto gli essi tre carte
chiaramente lentamente
inequivocabilmente equine rimanessero 1
2 3 4 5 e 6
qualcosa non quadra le maniche la prima
cosa che si pensa è quello nasconde le
carte nelle mani che aderì vero ho
trovato un metodo per nascondere sulle
maniche non si vede però quando serve ci
sono è loro uno dice ovvio ovvio anche
se tu togliessi tre carte chiaramente
lentamente inequivocabilmente anche se
non rimanessero solo tre
basta un attimo ed è per questo che vi
posso sempre a raccontare il famoso
gioco con una due tre quattro cinque e
sei carte ma rimane un dubbio
rimane un dubbio non le maniche ma le
carte come mai saranno quelle carte mi
sono organizzato ha già le mani
igienizzate veronica verificato che
siano esattamente insegnarle non sono
attaccate pc è esattamente quello che
sembrano grazie non è stato pericoloso
per ora stato importante perché
soprattutto adesso che ha esaminato
seduto gli assi tre carte
chiaramente lentamente
inequivocabilmente e rimanesse solo con
tre il punto è che senso a venire qui e
cercare di raccontarvi che esiste un
antico gioco nel quale ci sono 1 2 3 4 5
6 carte da cui se ne tolgono 3
chiaramente lentamente
inequivocabilmente è sempre sempre
sempre per il vostro piacere e
divertimento
questo rimane l'unico antico incredibile
gioco con una due tre quattro cinque e
sei carte e abbiamo rotto il ghiaccio
dunque dicevamo andare oltre i limiti è
stato detto che l'apertura l'area del
calabrone in relazione al suo peso non
gli permetterebbe di volare ma questo il
calabrone non lo sa e quindi vola lo
stesso ora veridicità scientifica a
parte è però vero che a volte a frenarci
non sono i limiti ma l'idea che dei
limiti possono esistere nel 1784 il
parroco di una chiesina della campagna
inglese un tal edmund cartwright
assistette alla dimostrazione di un
oggetto straordinario un automa
meccanismo che giocava a scacchi contro
le persone e vinceva sistematicamente
per cartwright fu una rivelazione
assoluta aver visto questa invenzione
meravigliosa all'opera lo ispirò l'idea
di fiducia e arrivo a costruire il primo
telaio meccanico che poi contribuirà
alla rivoluzione industriale perché
cartwright comincio a pensare ma anche a
dire ai suoi detrattori signori ma voi
non crederete che costruire una macchina
che tesse sia più complicato che
costruirne una che gioca a scacchi
però un problema l'automa giocatore di
scacchi non è proprio una macchina non
era nemmeno proprio un automa era uno
straordinario gioco di prestigio
inventato da un ingegnere con il cuore
di prestigiatore
ma questo il telaio di carta in 17 mai e
quindi continua a funzionare
e qui vi voglio mostrare l'immagine
della ricostruzione contemporanea
attuale che è stato fatto di quest'auto
me ne approfitto per ringraziare la
seconda persona che è alla mia sinistra
proprio dietro all'auto ma è simone
venturi un carissimo amico che mi è
stato di grande aiuto nel preparare
quello che vi sto raccontando oggi ecco
però oggi io sono qui anche grazie a
tanti maestri del passato che hanno
saputo alzare l'asticella hanno imposto
una nuova estetica e le loro conoscenze
sono state tramandate di generazione in
generazione attraverso i libri è una
pietra miliare in questo tipo di
letteratura è senza dubbio il discovery
of witchcraft scritto nel 1584 da
reginal scott che era un gentiluomo
inglese un giudice il quale rimase molto
turbato da aver assistito a un processo
18 presunte streghe poi anche condannate
e allora scrive un trattato nel quale
pur ammettendo che le streghe possano
esistere siamo pur sempre nel 1500 pur
ammettendo che le streghe possono
esistere mette in discussione la
stregoneria e le superstizioni della sua
epoca
in questo lavoro ci sono solamente 22
pagine dedicate ai giochi di prestigio
ma sono ovviamente un punto di svolta
nella divulgazione dell'arte vi mostro
il frontespizio del discovery perché vi
volevo raccontare si dice si racconta
che re giacomo primo il sovrano
dell'epoca fosse ossessionato da questo
libro e ordinò di cercare tutte le
coppie che si potessero trovare non per
leggerle si dice per mandare al rogo
perché sembra veridicità storica a parte
però è vero
libri fanno pure che le parole dei libri
possono far nascere mostri
nell'immaginazione di che legge così di
tanto in tanto arriva sempre qualcuno
che vorrebbe ridurre le pagine dei libri
al silenzio ma le parole rifiutano di
farsi imprigionare le idee sopravvivono
e noi siamo qui
cinquecento anni dopo a riportare in
vita le pagine di questi libri ea
celebrare il teatro del prestigiatore e
questo ve lo potevo far vedere e
mostrare solo adesso parlando del
discovery perché nel discovery fu
pubblicato in stampa per la prima volta
dunque riassumendo abbiamo detto studio
i libri lavoro applicazione non ci sono
scorciatoie
il gioco di prestigio naturalmente è
solamente la punta dell'iceberg è una
figura un'immagine che avete già visto
tante volte ma qui voglio precisare una
cosa
la cosa più importante che mi è stato
insegnato è che alla base il fondamento
di questa complessità poggia sulla
persona sull'individuo cioè sulla sua
cultura la sua sensibilità il suo
atteggiamento e per chiarire meglio
meglio quello che vi voglio dire faccio
prima un gioco perché credo che abbiate
sentito parlare del famoso gioco delle
tre carte
ecco io ne ho trovato una versione un po
particolare perché questo è l'unico
gioco delle tre carte fatto con 43 carte
bianche un asso di fiori che è la carta
vincente una delle carte bianche da
parte qui in piena vista la carta
vincente nel mezzo e si mescola in modo
che la gente possa seguire si sposta la
prima chiaramente che una carta bianca
si sposta la successiva che l'asso di
fiori la vincente si spostano successiva
che ha una carta bianca e poi come si
dice si scommette in mezzo e si perde
perché perché a ben guardare la prima la
seconda e la terza sono tre carte
bianche perché perché rapido veloce
invisibile spero insospettabile l'asso
di fiori passa ancora ancora una carta
da parte
la carta vincente nel mezzo si nel mezzo
e si mescola in modo che la gente possa
seguire si sposta la prima che
chiaramente una carta bianca si sposta
alla successiva la vincente si sposta la
successiva una carta bianca e poi si
scommette di solito in mezzo e si perde
perché perché rapido veloce invisibile
spero insospettabile l'asso di fiori
passa ora su questo gioco è nato una
leggenda metropolitana dicono le prime
volte che ti fanno giocare ti fanno
vincere per tirarti dentro per
coinvolgerti non è vero chi vince è
sempre un compare perché per esempio se
lei fosse stato il mio compare su per
giù sarebbe andata così carta bianca da
parte la carta vincente nel mezzo si nel
mezzo e si mescola si sposta la prima si
sposta alla seconda si sposta la terza
ma giocando con un compare se il mio
compare dicesse scegliesse questa carta
qui ci sarebbe un asso se mi dicesse la
carta di mezzo in mezzo ci sarebbe un
asso e si dicesse da quest'altra parte
anche da questa parte ci sarebbe un asso
perché quando si gioca con un compare le
regole cambiano con un compare si gioco
con tre assi e una sola carta bianca
morale morale non giocate mai a carte
con degli sconosciuti
specialmente quando sono degli amici ma
divertimento a parte quello che volevo
fare il punto è che quando uno
spettatore si trova di fronte a un gioco
di prestigio dovrebbe come si può dire
non sentirsi sminuito nella sua
intelligenza ma sentirsi arricchito per
aver visto qualcosa di bello frase
poetica e suggestiva ma come si fa
perché ci sono due fattori importanti il
primo fattore è lo stesso spettatore
voglio dire una parte dipende dalla sua
cultura della sua sensibilità della sua
disponibilità a giocare ed al suo
carattere ma c'è una parte di tutto
questo che è responsabilità del
prestigiatore a causa della particolare
struttura drammaturgica della
prestigiazione
tutte le narrazioni drammaturgiche tutte
le dramma delle drammaturgie si fondano
sul conflitto
il conflitto tra individuo e destino
come nell'edipo re conflitto tra genio e
mediocrità come in amadeus il film su
mozart nella precisazione potrebbe
essere conflitto tra individuo e leggi
limiti della natura ma nelle altre forme
narrative
quando si arriva al vertice della
narrazione al climate il conflitto i
conflitti vengono risolti l'eroe trionfa
il malvagio viene sconfitto e vissero
tutti felici e contenti
ecco però non solo ma nella parte
discendente di quella curva quello che
succede che per un po noi seguiamo anche
per un po ancora per un po le vicende
dei protagonisti
l'epilogo di star wars sono gli eroi che
vengono premiati il re leone sale sulla
rupe dei re e dunque questa è
tecnicamente una curva drammaturgica
completa cioè dal punto di vista
emozionale appaga completamente il
pubblico
purtroppo questa curva drammaturgica
completa non si può avere nella
prestigio nei questa è la curva della
prestigiazione perché quando ci arriva
il play max al gran finale del gioco per
risolvere il conflitto bisognerebbe
raccontare il segreto non si può
la curva si interrompe rimane un vuoto
quel vuoto
noi lo chiamiamo in gergo il conflitto
intellettuale che tradotto in un
linguaggio corrente è ma come fa
e qui è dove entra in gioco la
sensibilità e l'atteggiamento del
prestigiatore perché è evidente che un
prestigiatore arrogante e presuntuoso e
saccente anche avendo uno spettatore ben
disposto
non lo metterebbe in grado di cogliere
la bellezza della meraviglia diciamo che
dovrebbe essere come ho sentito dire a
salvatore accardo quando in
un'intervista parlando di maurizio
pulina ha detto quando lo ascolto
suonare sempre che mi stia dicendo
ascolta come è bella questa musica e non
ammira come sono bravo
ora detto questo nel poco tempo che
rimane vi devo raccontare quali sono i
nuovi limiti verso i quali va la
l'associazione dunque le avanguardie è
curioso che per parlare delle
avanguardie devo primo utilizzare un
gioco farvi vedere un gioco di 500 anni
fa e qui
molti diranno anno questo gioco lo ho
già visto lo so però credo che avrò da
dirgli qualcosa di un pò sorprendente su
questo inatteso diciamo inatteso è un
gioco classico i giochi classici sono
quelli che pur esistendo letteralmente
da secoli continuano ad esercitare un
indiscusso fascino sui prestigiatori
sugli spettatori
ma come mai questo succede perché lo
vedremo poi intanto guardate come è
bello questo gioco perché nel mio
mestiere
il punto non è tanto far vedere le cose
il punto è farle credere
e questo è credibile anzitutto perché si
vede chiaramente si vede cosa succede e
non solo si vede credo che avvicinando
un microfono
spero che si senta e non solo si vede e
si sente veronica ancora bisogno di te
tutto stessa rompi lo è convincente e la
aspetta ancora uno è convincente grazie
allora da qui in avanti guardate io mi
muovo con chiarezza devo tutto sulla
punta delle dita voi però ricordate il
punto dal quale siamo partiti agli altri
pezzetti si avvolgono chiaramente
lentamente e si fissano circa a metà del
capo principale è un attimo è così circa
a metà dicevamo del capo principale non
è proprio un po più piccolo un poco più
al centro e dicevamo il punto non è
solamente far vedere il punto e far
credere
e se funzionasse piano piano torneremmo
all'inizio del nostro filo del discorso
e soprattutto e soprattutto spero che
qualcuno di voi abbia un po come si può
dire rivissuto la stessa sensazione che
può aver rivissuto 500 anni fa
quell'uomo quella donna che per primi
hanno visto questo questo gioco dunque
dicevamo le avanguardie il motore
dell'avanguardia è senza dubbio uno dei
motori la esco e la magica di madrid
un gruppo di lavoro la cui diciamo anima
e quanta amarezza un maestro un mio
maestro e mentore e il quale ha spesso
proposto di punti di vista piuttosto
innovativi sulla prestazione ha indicato
delle strade nuovo per esempio l'idea
che i giochi classici siano
sopravvissuti nei secoli perché hanno
dei valori simbolici intrinseci cioè
provocano rispettato re delle emozioni
insolitamente profonde anche livello
inconscio gli oggetti che o gli animali
vivi che appaiono dal nulla rimandano
chiaramente all'idea della della
creazione dal nulla
gli anelli quelli che si legano che si
slegano noi li chiamiamo nelle cinesi in
gergo certo l'idea della libertà
però mi ha fatto notare un caro amico il
professor pietro francini esimio
psicoterapeuta psicoanalista è anche la
storia di una unione che permette una
autonomia cioè di essere legati ma
separabili quando necessario separabili
ma non separati la corda tagliata e a
maggior ragione il filo che hanno scelto
perché soprattutto nella nostra cultura
si avvicina molto all'idea delle delle
parche al mito delle parche e mercier
liete elia dello storico delle religioni
si dice che in tutte le culture è
presente l'idea del filo come simbolo
della vita ecco il riaggiustarlo rimanda
all'idea di riuscire a sfuggire alla
morte o se vogliamo essere meno
drammatici la possibilità di recuperare
una integrità perduta
ecco si ritiene che la consapevolezza di
questi aspetti culturali sia il punto di
partenza per le avanguardie verso una
nuova sperimentazione e per concludere
ho scelto un gioco vi lascio con un
gioco che ha una caratteristica racconta
un'altra cosa particolare della
prestigiazione perché c'è il teatro che
mette insieme alla vita il cinema che
per definizione è la fabbrica dei sogni
ma questa è l'unica forma di spettacolo
dove qualcosa di surreale sembra stia
veramente accadendo qui nella realtà
qualunque cosa questa parola voglia dire
e ho imparato a modellare l'oggetto più
semplice con la carta fatto non ditemi
che è un buco datemi ancora una
possibilità nuovo lentamente tenendo
tutto ben in vista sul palmo della mano
e piano piano sembra ci vuole il suo
tempo ma per essere un pezzo di carta
comincia a sembrare un nuovo sembra ma
la cosa affascinante se funzionasse
quando funziona è che questo è un uomo
perché perché molte cose molte cose non
si prova nemmeno a farle perché sembrano
impossibili e molte cose sembrano
impossibili perchè non si prova nemmeno
a farle grazie